hey 42 here you may be surprised to hear
that's a lot of things you do that you
think are perfectly innocent may in fact
be illegal imagine this scene you're in
a pub with your mates watching the game
and you decide to make a bet on the
game's outcome but if you bet over
$2,000 you just broke the law and it can
land you up to ten years in prison
this actually happened in 2005 when a
cop overheard a guy named Sal colossi
make a bet of over $2,000 in a bar the
next morning a SWAT team arrived at his
doorstep to arrest him and shot him
through the heart
number two is connecting to unsecured
Wi-Fi networks connecting to any
wireless network you don't own or have
permission to use even if it isn't
password-protected can land you in
prison for at least two years and you
may have to pay up to at least a $10,000
fine considering that most modern phones
and wireless devices automatically seek
out and connect to nearby Wi-Fi networks
makes this an extremely easy law to
break it's extremely unlikely you'll
actually be caught in the act despite
this there have been at least four known
cases in the US where people have been
arrested and locked up for using other
people's Wi-Fi speaking of the Internet
and number three is using a fake name
online it may sound stupid but the next
time you sign up to a web site under the
alias of super-ninja 66 you've actually
broken the law is considered illegal
under the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act
to fake your identity online and can net
you between five and 20 years in prison
at four is writing disturbing material
ok this doesn't apply everywhere but in
some US states for example Illinois it
is illegal to write disturbing fiction
it doesn't even matter if you publish it
or not
someone finds a serving material like
you've written and finds it offensive
you could be fined up to $1500 and
spends 30 days in jail it's even worse
in Oklahoma where you can face up to ten
years in prison for writing a fictional
story wherein a person gets injured or
killed at five is a peculiar law you've
probably broken countless times in your
life in the UK uncertain US states such
as Alaska it is actually illegal to be
drunk in a pub or a bar the law defines
being drunk is having lost steady self
control although very few people are
ever prosecuted for this in practice the
courts use markers such as glazed eyes
slurred speech and unsteadiness to
determine if one is properly badgered
enough to face charges for being drunk
in a pub number six is a law that you've
probably contravened more than any it is
illegal to sing happy birthday in public
why because it's copyrighted
in 1988 warner/chappell music purchased
the rights to the song for 25 million
dollars meaning restaurants that play
this song have to pay royalties to
Warner collectively these royalties net
Warner a handsome two million dollars a
year in 1995 the American Society of
Composers Authors and publishers tried
to extort money from 2300 Girl Scout
groups because they regularly sang happy
birthday around the campfire without
paying royalties however the American
press released a PR nightmare upon ASCAP
and they quickly back down once they
realized what otter tits they were being
unfine aliy in most of the u.s. it's
illegal to possess a permanent marker or
aerosol can in public if you are under
the age of 18 so if you ever took part
in an arts and crafts day as a child
you're technically a hardened criminal
there is a controversial case in 2010
where a 13 year old Oklahoma City boy
was arrested for using a permanent
marker in plots
the team is writing on a piece of paper
using a permanent marker and the ink had
bled through onto the desk underneath
his teacher actually made a citizen's
arrest on the kid and he was handed over
to the police and arrested thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2